Morning.
- Will you stay a while?
- A little while.
But not to worry. I'll see you at the Christening.
(Director) And... go!
Hello, Beastie.
I missed you.
(Director) 3, 2, 1 go!
Will you try with a little less... fang?
Of this so very kind of you to invite me this evening.
Better.
Now with a curtsy?
Let's skip that part.
Well, I'm queen of the Moors and I am human.
Well, there are many who prey on the innocent.
I'm sure your kind would agree.
- My kind?
- She means humans
Can we just listen to the music? I remember the story of a baby...
A baby cursed to sleep and...
never wake up
Really?
Who would do such a terrible thing to an innocent child?
Well, there are many who prey on the innocent.
I'm sure your kind would agree.
- What do you mean my kind?
- She means humans.
- There are fairies missing from the Moors...
- What I'm missing is some wine.
stolen by human poachers.
- That's the first I've heard of it.
- Someone gave the order.
Now we will have our war.
What about Maleficent?
Our fight begins now.
Our fight begins now!
Conan wanted peace, and they filled him with iron.
Now we will have our war.
Maybe she's right.
Know it everyone, especially the king.
What about Maleficent?
Oh, yeah
Like don't like this
I wore it.
Sure, it's perfect.
So am I.
Did you like a little pricey yoohoo guess the nominee they're on their
Gun crazy comedy
It's so funny with them in the modern world like polar
You
So you can do better when you do very well very well I
When when Pinto comes closer we need to come JIP down on the on the army
I think budget. I mean this one we see ghosts. We should book what we don't and then we have been open up Aurora
She walks
My opening